here's a story from the Wall Street
Journal the latest I'm sure many of you
have heard about what's been going on
between Israel and Palestine Hamas
threatens to execute Israelis in
response to bombing of Gaza we have an
image here shocking image flames and
smoke billow during Israeli strikes in
Gaza on Monday these photos are
absolutely crazy there's videos now
emerging from Gaza as Israel retaliates
Over The Killing of civilians I believe
it is estimated at 900 plus dead the
number is probably higher now think
it's, 1,100 I I seen something similar
so of course there's going to be
retaliation the Walsh Journal says Hamas
on Monday threatened to execute Israeli
hostages if Israel continues to bombard
civilian homes in Gaza without warning
from this hour on WE announc that any
targeting of Civilian homes that
advanced warning will be met regrettably
with the execution of one of the enemy
civilian hostages we hold and we'll be
forced to broadcast broadcast this says
Abu obida the spokesman for hamas's
military Wing alqassam brigades inim
marks broadcast on pan Arab Channel Al
jazer the enemy does not understand the
language of humanity and morals and we
will address him in the language he
knows we hold the occupation responsible
for this decision in front of the world
I'm sorry I mean it's plain as day these
are not Secrets this is not someone uh
this is not a fake video produced this a
a human being saying yes we we stormed
into the civilian areas kidnapped and
and and and captured civilians that we
consider enemies and that they intend
that that they're now saying they intend
to
kill okay this argument about Freedom
Fighters or whatever not doesn't fly I I
I'm not going to buite you want to come
at me and talk about war and history and
Israel and occupation like let's have a
conversation we can talk about the West
Bank we can talk about uh uh people
going to the West Bank and bulldozing
homes or or or seizing property all of
that stuff we can have a conversation
but this right here there's zero
justification there are people right now
in New York I shouldn't say right now
but probably right now over this past
weekend celebrating the killing of
civilian
ions so what is this where where do we
go from here this is a war of
colonization and it's the first time
we've ever seen it on TV in real time
it's happened for for the history of
mankind but you only hear like they went
in and they marauded 18 border towns and
then they were there and they destroyed
the crops and then they came back but
you don't hear you didn't see them
murdering the people raping the women uh
kidnapping the children to raise as
their own like you don't see that and
now we see it and this is what it looks
like yeah it's a strange part of Modern
Warfare how quickly we can see what's
going on on the ground especially given
the wide access of the internet I mean
there are a number of people that I
would be interested to hear their take
the Hadid sisters are obviously uh not
what I would call political influencers
but they have been very vocally Pro
Palestine given their Heritage um it's
just um it's been a crazy weekend it's
been a lot of um sort of a delug of
information I yeah I don't know what's
real and what's not that's part of why
this this is a this is an opportunity to
speak scientifically on on what I've
seen over the weekend I suppose I what I
find really fascinating about this is
that you have far-
leftists and what do you what do you
call what do you call this um I don't
even know what you'd call the the
faction of anti-semetic or anti-israel
I'm not saying literally the same thing
there's people who hate Jewish people
people who hate Israel or let's let's
try and and tone it down as much as
possible there are people who reject the
idea of Israel who are considered who
are more Nationalist and and there white
nationalists they're
aligned in this regard with the far-left
completely not not in the sense of like
Pro Palestine but in opposition to
Israel as a state and it's just a very
very weird circumstance to see prominent
conservatives now completely in
agreement with the Democrats
surprisingly it's like all of a sudden
like whoa It's just Ming and mashing
everything
up yeah it is I mean I think it's uh
reflective of a lot of stuff that's
going on in our country where we have
been used to uh certain political
parties claiming certain certain values
and ultimately um especially in
complicated nuanced situations people
you wouldn't expect to agree actually
have common ground when I think of farle
I think of people that support Palestine
and that's what I've I've always kind of
ass ass and it may not be true but the
people on the far left are like no
Israel is an invading Force we need to
but then the the Biden administrations
engaged with the far-left had this these
people and this is Maybe I'm just
misreading the situation through the
media I've been I've been watching but
and now Biden sent an aircraft carrier
over there to support Israel but his
constituency is like the left and they
don't want they support Palestine and
it's a very broad General assumption but
that's a that's a conflict of interest
um and maybe that's a good thing well I
think there's no room for the Nuance
take here which is obviously Israel has
a right to respond and fight Hamas
because they were attacked in a vicious
terrorist attack but that we should be
focused on making sure this thing
doesn't break out into World War II that
is what the US's interest is here you
know I'm not you're right in essence but
considering who's in charge of this
country I'm not so sure their interests
align with what you're describing I
think a lot of these companies have
vested interest in World War II and then
there's a big question about what
constitutes World War III with the start
of the of the uh with with the Russian
invasion of Ukraine or you can even go
back to say like the US backed ousting
of yanukovich in Ukraine whatever you
want I mean these things can all be
reduced you can go way back in time but
with the conflict the hot conflict
you've got prominent people in Europe
saying this is World War III already now
you add into the mix what will likely be
the most dramatic and
egregious military escalation from
Israel into Gaza that we've ever seen
and may result in the end of Gaza I mean
the the videos that are coming out of
buildings being leveled it's it's brutal
they're saying this is R
911 this could be World War II I mean
look I know everybody's always like oh
you're being sensationalist by saying
World War I I will just say this for all
I know tomorrow everybody stops there's
a there's tears some you know profit
emerges who knows and everyone stops
fighting and they're like I can't
believe we fought then they all hug and
it's like rainbows okay for all for all
you know that happens even though the
conflict's been going on for Generations
if not Millennia maybe but if China
invades Taiwan and sees and tries to
take it right now then I think it's fair
to say like objectively okay World War
III we've got these massive superpower
involved hot conflicts popping up all
over the globe and even then maybe it's
still Fair it's still fair that that
there would be some argument against it
no maybe it's just regional conflict
right if this does devolve into the US
mobilizing Russia mobilizing China
mobilizing into an actual easily
discernable World War III with front
with a front line a western front they
will look back historically and this
will be a part of that war right so when
when when France Ferdinand died no one
said that's it World War I just start
World War I's on everybody we postdated
it we said oh that was the start exactly
I kind of get the vibe that it was 911
is what is what catapulted us into the
age of world
chaos I don't know uh look there's been
there's been there was Desert Storm
there there's a whole bunch of conflicts
between the US and and and other
countries and it never ended I mean
after the cold during the Cold War we
had a whole bunch of wars and conflict
it's not stopped there was a period
where it was a little quieter but there
was still Afghanistan and Iraq and one
World War I and two was like the same
War there was that interwar period where
Germany was just Ste seething because
half the or part of the country had been
Stripped Away and given to Poland and
those native Germans that were now under
the control the poles were being
executed and genocided and the Germans
were like you know cast this belly for
war we need to take our land back and it
there's just like one big war with like
10 years of like quiet time yeah I mean
that's probably true of all conflict in
world history of all time right like we
say a war ends but does it really
because the Fallout is what sets up the
next one I mean that's going to be true
obvious it's true now this how we got
here and it's also will be true forever
right we I I love the idea that we'd
live in peace But ultimately someone is
a loser when you live in peace there's
always going to be tension there's the
one of the arguments they're putting
forward right now is that 75 years ago
Israel seized uh Israeli Israeli
militants and militias seized land from
Palestinians it's like okay I get it you
know people were kicked out of their
home 75 years ago I don't see how that
justifies kidnapping and murdering
Germans you know like that there's that
video going around that tattoo artist
who was dancing at the festival and
there are people in New York celebrating
that hipsters at a festival got taken
and the guy laughs and says I'm sure
they're doing fine now he knows they
were all murdered they were all murdered
they their dead bodies paraded around
dude you want to talk about war and
conflict fine but like if if they were
really trying to say like take back
their homes or tear down the fences of
an open air prison which by all means
make all these arguments I don't see how
they're like we we've escaped the prison
quick go kill civilians like imagine
there's a dude who claims he was
wrongfully jailed and he's in prison and
he's like I shouldn't be here I'm
innocent I was forced in here by
corruption and tyranny I'm a political
prisoner and then he breaks out and then
he runs straight for some 20-y oldold
woman and just beats her to death you'd
be like dude you should have been in
prison I think that a lot the majority
probably a grand majority of the people
in Palestine in in in Gaza whatever you
want to call it they they call some
people call some people call Palestine
whatever Gaza is the strip left over of
Palestine basically and the West Bank as
well as Palestine so they're not violent
they're just stuck and and they're
trying to live but then there's militant
very angry small group of militant
activists Hamas and others you know that
are willing to kill and are are creating
a situation where these civilians are
now in the line of fire it's true for a
lot of civilians there are there are a
lot of programs that try to uh bring Aid
to to the GSA strip I remember uh it's a
really really crazy thing when I went to
Israel and I was in Tel Aviv and uh I I
know people who were involved in
skateboard projects in Gaza and people
skate in G in Gaza and uh I'm talking to
this Israeli uh person about you know
like it was really cool to see in the
United States a Palestinian from Gaza
who made it to the US and was
skateboarding with an Israeli and
they're like high-fiving and fist
bumping being like you know we could if
only we could find this kind of peace
and then the Israeli guy goes no they
don't skateboard and I was like what yes
they do there's like skate park and go
no there's not and I was like yeah there
is Google it right now I'll pull the
video up for you like I'm just like do
you genuinely think that's not true like
and I think the issue was that for a lot
of these more um liberal-minded like
this this uh this German citizen who is
who was reportedly killed was a a German
National but also dual citizen Israeli
conscien objector and pacifist and it's
these people who are raised in this U um
left liberal leftist mindset liberal
mindset of World Peace
and perhaps they saw one of these videos
of this dude from Palestine fist bumping
a guy from Israel of course Palestinians
got really mad about that but the dudes
in America he like I just want to escape
man leave me alone like they don't care
about anything else and uh and I've also
heard the inverse too but they see
stories like this and like we can't have
peace and then like I'll say it again
like call it an open air prison that's
fine I got no aru like let's have an
argument we'll talk about it whatever
you can call what you want but if you're
going to make the argument that they're
trying to break free then they just run
out and start killing people and the
woman who got killed was the is pacifist
it's like well I was a cold hard lesson
in gun control and peace when there are
people who believe that you as a
civilian and a tourist are an evil per
evil that needs to be purged there's no
negotiating somebody dancing to music
well we could we can argue about like uh
LW and lascivious behavior and stuff and
like the the de Evolution or the
degradation of society and stuff but
come on man like what's the
justification for running into a music
festival and just gunning people down
because to in their mind it doesn't
matter who you are you're all evil so
it's like how are you supposed to have
what's Justice in this situation if
these people in New York are chanting
from The River To The Sea they're
talking about genocide they're talking
about Mass execution dude I'll say it
again you want to talk about 1948 you
want to talk about the British occupied
Palestine and all of that stuff let's
have a conversation but you ain't
getting anything from me when you are
literally singing songs about Mass
executing all the civilians who live
there yeah it was 1918 I think when the
British mandate for Palestine and okay
I'm not exactly sure what year I think
there was something called the Bal for
Declaration was signed and what happened
was during World War I the the British
and the French were like we cannot win
we're going to lose the Ottoman Empire
is annihilating us the Germans the
austrians they're too powerful so they
made a deal with the Ottomans and they
were like we will give actually let no
let me let me fix that they made a deal
with the Arabs not the Ottomans they
made a deal with the Arabs the Arabs
were also with Germans and the austrians
so the the British and the French May
deal with the Arabs and they said if you
help us win if you turn on the Ottoman
Empire we'll give you this area which is
now Israel we'll give this to you Arabs
so the Arabs said okay so they turned on
the Ottomans and then we they won we won
the war and then they went back on their
offer and they said no we're going to
keep that area for oursel and they set
up the British mandate for Palestine and
occupied it and ever since that's like
the Inception point of when the Arabs
are like you you promised us our land
back like you you were we helped you we
died for you and and now you took it and
now you're there and and that was it it
that's where it began and then there's
something called the Sykes Pico
agreement where I think Israel was
officially formed I don't want to speak
too much on this but there's something
called the Sykes Pico agreement which is
worth looking into too this is one of
the reasons why I'm like very anti-
intervention I never say I'm like
absolutely anti- intervention because
sometimes I recognize like not
everything's absolute but the problem is
you've got a lot of people who don't
know enough about any of this and it's
so fervent and insane the people being
like Israel has a right blah blah blah
and the you know whatever and I'm like
bro I'm sitting here watching people
kill kill civilians saying like hey
don't kill civilians and then people are
still mad it's crazy like the the the
the pro-israel side is saying like
they're justified in everything they're
doing and whatever uh in retaliation and
then the pro palestin side are are
saying that they're justified in in in
you know pushing out these these
occupiers and I'm like bro it's like a
20-year-old woman at a music festival
got killed not the only one and of
course I understand there's fog of war
and there's propaganda but dude like
nobody nobody mass-produced big fake
videos uh and got these guys to go on TV
and admit to doing these things mhm I
mean this is how I felt when we got
involved with Ukraine right what is the
American interest here and do we
actually have one I understand calls for
you know you got to protect innocent
people and you know whatever but
ultimately all of these things are much
more nuanced conflicts than the American
Media presents to the people and we use
it to justify investing tons and tons of
money into stuff that I'm not sure is in
the best interest of American people
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at 10 cast.com
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time